Il s'avère que la psychologie en sait beaucoup sur ces choses.
Vraiment beaucoup.
Mais je n'entendais pas de références
dans mon cours d'études environnementales,
durant les réunions d'action climatique auxquelles j'allais
ou les conférences internationales
où tout le monde demande :
pourquoi n'agissons-nous pas plus vite et que nous faut-il pour agir ?
Cela est en quelque sorte devenu ma mission :
me saisir de connaissances tirées de la psychologie
et les traduire en ressources et outils
pour soutenir ceux qui travaillent en première ligne pour changer les choses.
D'ailleurs, ça veut dire tout le monde.
Nous sommes tous actuellement en première ligne.
Je crois,
après des années à cheval entre ces mondes,
entre l'environnement, le climat et la psychologie,
que c'est un ingrédient qui manque à notre travail
et qui peut accélérer exponentiellement notre capacité à être créatifs,
résilients, capables, compétents, courageux
et toutes ces choses que le monde requiert de notre part.
Je vais partager avec vous trois concepts
que j'ai trouvés révolutionnaires
et le sens qu'ils prennent en ce moment
pour nous êtres humains.
Le premier s'appelle notre fenêtre de tolérance.
Le Dr Dan Siegel nous a décrits comme ayant tous une fenêtre.
La quantité de stress que nous pouvons tolérer
tout en demeurant connecté
et ce que les cliniciens appelleraient « intégré ».
Être intégré, c'est quand nous pouvons
être connecté à nos pensées et émotions
et ne pas seulement y être assimilé.
Nous avons tous un seuil.
Que se passe-t-il quand nous subissons un stress
au-delà de ce que nous pouvons tolérer ?
Nous avons tendance à aller vers les bords de notre fenêtre.
D'un côté,
nous pourrions tomber dans une sorte d'épuisement,
ce qu'on appelle une réponse chaotique
et qui ressemble à de la dépression, du désespoir,
une sorte d'interruption.
De l'autre côté de cette fenêtre, il y a une réponse plus rigide :
le déni,
la colère,
la rigidité.
Quand cela arrive,
nous perdons notre capacité à être intégré,
résilient, adaptatif,
toutes ces choses que nous voulons être.
C'est tout à fait normal,
mais cela arrive actuellement à travers le monde.
Nous oscillons tous entre ces différents ressentis et émotions.
Avec quelque chose comme le changement climatique,
avec chaque rapport scientifique,
chaque documentaire
qui relie ce que nous faisons
à l'impact que cela a,
cela peut collectivement nous pousser en dehors de notre fenêtre de tolérance.
Nous pouvons perdre cette capacité.
Au fil des années, j'ai interviewé des centaines de personnes
issues de tous milieux et de toutes appartenances politiques,
du Midwest américain à la Chine,
et j'ai parlé à des gens de nos sentiments concernant ce qu'il se passe.
Pas de nos opinions et croyances.
De nos sentiments
concernant ce qu'il arrive à notre environnement local,
notre eau, notre sol, la situation globale.
Ce que les gens me disent
presque systématiquement,
c'est un attachement.
A un moment de la conversation, les gens me disent :
« Ce qu'il se passe m'inquiète beaucoup,
je suis paniqué.
J'ai peur,
j'adore ce pays, j'adore les oiseaux, » -
quoi que ce soit -
« mais j'ai l'impression que mes actions sont insignifiantes.
Je ne sais pas où commencer.
Et je suis aussi » -
- je le ressens en filigrane -
« j'ai très peur de changer.
J'ai peur de tout changement, c'est si --
Je ne peux même pas y penser, c'est impensable. »
C'est le second concept,
quelque chose que l'on appelle une double contrainte.
Une double contrainte,
c'est quand nous avons l'impression d'être fichu quoi que nous fassions
et d'être coincé au milieu.
C'est une expérience humaine intolérable.
Nous ferons tout notre possible
pour nous en débarrasser et nous en éloigner.
Toute cette inquiétude et cette préoccupation
sont là et se volatilisent, disparaissent.
Ce qui arrive,
c'est qu'il semble que cela n'importe pas aux gens,
cela ressemble à de l'apathie.
De nombreuses personnes qui perçoivent l'urgence de la situation
disent : « Nous devons vous motiver.
Nous devons vous enthousiasmer. »
Et nous nous faisons les porte-paroles des solutions.
Ou : « Voici les faits, cela arrive, réveillez-vous. »
Ces choses ne sont pas intrinsèquement mauvaises,
car nous avons besoin de solutions et d'être confrontés aux faits.
Mais par inadvertance, cela peut avoir l'effet inverse à celui prévu
et mener à plus d'insensibilisation et d'inaction,
ce qui rend perplexes de nombreuses personnes.
Que se passe-t-il ?
C'est à cause de cela,
car cela ne touche pas vraiment à ce qu'il se passe plus profondément.
Imaginez que vous alliez voir un thérapeute
et que vous ayez une double contrainte.
Vous avez l'impression d'être coincé,
vous savez que vous devez changer
et le thérapeute commence à vous crier dessus
en disant : « Vous ne voyez pas ce qu'il se passe ?
Si vous n'agissez pas maintenant,
vous ferez face à des conséquences terrifiantes.
Vous vous en fichez donc ?
C'est quoi votre problème ?
Qu'est-ce qu'il vous faut ? »
Ou vous voyez un thérapeute et vous ressentez de la tristesse
et du chagrin.
Et ce thérapeute dit :
« N'y pensez pas trop.
Voici quelques choses simples que vous pouvez faire.
Des choses simples et positives. »
Puis il vous renvoie chez vous.
Si c'était moi,
je virerais immédiatement ce thérapeute,
car un bon thérapeute pratique une chose appelée l'harmonisation.
J'aime tellement ce concept.
L'harmonisation, le mot fait pour harmoniser.
L'harmonisation, c'est quand nous nous sentons en phase,
quand nous nous sentons compris
et quand nous nous sentons acceptés dans notre situation actuelle.
Nous avons l'impression
d'avoir une relation avec le monde qui est sensée,
personne n'essaye de nous changer,
de nous couvrir de honte ou de nous juger.
Oui ?
L'harmonisation nécessite des compétences.
Quand les enjeux sont élevés,
il est très difficile de vouloir s'harmoniser avec quoi que ce soit
quand nous sommes confrontés à des menaces si urgentes.
Mais le paradoxe du moment que nous vivons
est que quand nous sommes plus en phase avec notre fenêtre de tolérance,
nous sommes bien plus capable de résoudre des problèmes,
d'être créatif, d'être adaptatif,
d'être flexible,
d'être brillamment nous-mêmes.
Et si notre travail sur le climat et l'environnement
était informé par ces concepts
de fenêtre de tolérance,
de nombreuses doubles contraintes
et d'harmonisation ?
Cela peut sembler faire beaucoup.
On me demande constamment :
« D'accord Renée, cela semble super dans un contexte clinique,
nous n'avons pas le temps pour cela. »
Cela n'est absolument pas vrai.
Nous pouvons infuser de l'harmonisation
dans chaque aspect de notre travail à ce sujet.
Cela commence par nous-mêmes.
Vous ne pouvez pas réaliser d'harmonisation
sans être en phase avec vous-même,
désolée de vous l'annoncer.
C'est incontournable.
Cela vient de l'intérieur.
Cela commence par écouter ce que vous ressentez.
Et en étant plein de compassion.
C'est facile à dire
mais être plein de compassion --
il s'agit de sujets difficiles.
C'est un moment difficile pour un être humain,
nous nous réveillons.
Je ne suis pas quelqu'un de mauvais.
Ce qu'il se passe
fait naître de la curiosité au sein de notre expérience,
ce qui nous permet de nous harmoniser socialement.
C'est la façon suivante d'appliquer cela :
l'harmonisation dans de petits groupes,
en tête-à-tête,
dans les campagnes, les stratégies, les salles de classe, au cinéma,
dans les parcs.
Là où nous pouvons donner à l'autre la permission d'être nous-mêmes
et à nouveau, cela nous permet d'aller
vers des fonctions cognitives supérieures.
Les fonctions exécutives, le cortex préfrontal,
qui nous fait sentir que notre système nerveux peut se calmer
et que nous sommes compris par l'autre.
La troisième façon est de mener avec de l'harmonisation.
En tant que leaders et personnes influentes,
se montrer humain, authentique,
dire : « Vous savez quoi ?
J'ai très peur.
Je ne connais pas les réponses. »
Pouvez-vous imaginer des leaders disant cela ?
« Je ne sais pas.
Mais voilà où nous en sommes et nous avons besoin de chacun.
Nous sommes dans le même bateau.
Nous pouvons le faire. »
C'est un message très différent de : « Nous pouvons le faire ».
C'est dire : « Voilà la situation.
J'ai peur, mais voilà ce qu'il se passe. »
Alors voilà :
tous ces travaux existent,
nous avons les outils pour créer ces conditions
pouvant nous permettre de nous révéler
comme étant brillamment nous-mêmes.
Je sais, sans doute aucun, avec 100% de certitude,
que chacun d'entre nous a la capacité
de relever ces défis avec l'ingénuité,
avec le brio et avec le courage que nous êtres humains avons.
Nous devons simplement cultiver ensemble les conditions.
Nous avons besoin les uns des autres
pour nous soutenir les uns les autres
et nous permettre de relever ce défi.
C'est ce dont nous avons besoin, donc...
Prenons une profonde inspiration.
Faisons preuve de compassion envers nous-mêmes
et envers les autres à cet instant, à ce moment de l'histoire,
afin de collectivement digérer ces vérités douloureuses,
ces réalités difficiles.
Faisons-le ensemble.
Le monde est prêt à ce que nous le fassions.
Et nous pouvons le faire.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)